wie bewerten sie die einigung das hat
wenig mit europäischer solidarität zu
tun aber viel mit eu geschacher mit
hintergrund zusatzdienst und fast schon
offene erpressung und dabei ist
kanzlerin merkel den
stabilitätsorientierten ländern der
österreich wie holland schweden dänemark
in den rücken gefallen das darf gar
nicht sein
wo sehen sie die schwächen design und
inhaltlichen das ist eine neue schulden
union die es hier gibt eine riesige
umverteilung
das darf nicht sein dass die
stabilitätsorientierten länder die über
jahrzehnte solide gewirtschaftet haben
für die missstände in den südlichen
ländern verantwortlich gemacht werden
alle länder der erde müssen mit corona
klar kommen ohne ihre nachbarn
anzupumpen europäische solidarität ist
gut aber dieses verfahren dieses geschah
hat das geht gar nicht
gelder verschwendet worden
die werden dadurch verschwendet in dem
die fleißigen stabilitätsorientierten
soliden sparer im norden jetzt haften
müssen für jahrzehntelange finanzielle
unsolide politik für viel zu hohe renten
im süden viel zu frühe
renteneintrittsalter viel zu hohe
beamten und so weiter bezahlungen kriegt
man auch weiter machen das ist nach den
eu-verträgen eigentlich ausgeschlossen
und rechtswidrig und darf auch überhaupt
nicht sein dass werden die bürger auf
dauer auch nicht mitmachen sie wollen
nicht für die schulden anderer länder
haften das argument der bundesregierung
ist ja wir stärken länder um auch dort
absatzmärkte für halt weil das natürlich
auch im sinne eines europäischen
binnenmarktes ist was spricht aus ihrer
sicht aber da sind die länder doch
eigenverantwortlich die nationalstaaten
die steuerzahler die politiken sind
eigenverantwortlich nehmen wir alle
länder unterstützen müssen mit krediten
und geschenkt damit sie unsere produkte
kaufen das kann nicht sein so
funktioniert auch keine marktwirtschaft